this is from the federalist it says
nearly half of the nation's children
aged 5 through 11 now qualify as either
overweight or obese according to results
of a new study out friday
researchers from the university of
southern california and the university
of michigan found the proportion
of u.s children age 5 between 5 and 11
who are overweight and obese on the body
mass index rose from just more than
36 percent pre-pandemic to nearly 40 to
nearly 46
over the course of prolonged classroom
closures
uh dr tim lodgeman says school is
essential kids are eating ultra
processed foods locked in at home and
it's making them sicker
a literature review on effective
strategies for childhood obesity
prevention published in may of last year
lends credence to lo lojimin's claims
um
according to a team of 19 european
researchers who reviewed more than 400
studies from 2000 to january 2015
school-based programs to mitigate
childhood obesity were found far more
effective than seminars directed at
parents to teach healthy living at home
okay so there are
there are assumptions here that
that i don't agree with and one of one
of the assumptions
is that
parents are incapable of
preventing their children
from becoming fat
or the idea that parents need seminars
in the first place
it's more effective than a seminar like
i don't need my children are not obese
i don't need any seminar for that
they don't they don't drink soda hardly
at all we don't have a lot of junk food
in the house
and uh they they we they get plenty of
exercise they run around and play all
the time we're always making sure that
they're we get them off the couch
they don't have phones they don't sit
around the couch all day looking at
phones
limit the tv time
and all the rest of the time we say what
my parents said to me when i was a kid
and i said i'm
i'm bored
well you can go outside and play or you
could do some chores what do you think
what those are your two options if
you're bored i'll i'll help you out i'll
make sure you're not bored anymore
so i don't need any seminars i already
know that
the idea that
the kids need to go to school so that
they don't become
obese is absurd
but
the connection between
the lockdowns and obesity
is it's pretty obvious i mean it's not a
coincidence
that we've seen a 10
spike in childhood obesity which was
already
sky high i mean 36
especially when you consider what it
takes
to be obese as a child
this should be something that we're all
used to seeing obese children walking
around and it's very sad to see but this
should be something like you almost
never see this should be seeing an obese
child should be like it should be like
you know
it it should be like it's like spotting
a unicorn or something it should be just
something you never see
because children are you know they've
got very active metabolisms naturally
and they're very and they should be
active themselves naturally they've got
a ton of energy
it's extremely and you can control
everything they eat they're not eating
anything you don't give to them
you don't want you don't want your kid
to be obese just don't have soda in the
house
don't have junk food and and don't let
them sit on the couch all day boom done
no more obesity of children
36 is crazy 46 is even more crazy 10
hike it's clearly clearly there's a um
connection but i would say the
connection is less the fact that they're
that they weren't going to school and
more the fact that uh so many parents
kept their kids locked inside and at the
same time we shut down the playgrounds
but let's let's never forget that
even where i lived you know they were
they were putting caution tape around
playgrounds like it's a crime scene
taking the uh the basketball hoops down
and basketball courts and you just take
away the opportunities for kids and then
a lot of crazy parents also didn't want
their kids going outside they're afraid
that their kid walked down the front
yard the coronavirus was going to come
in and you know assault them
so
that's the connection but there very
clearly is a connection
and as we hear about
um
coronavirus among children and we we
know
that it is very rarely severe among kids
they're at much higher risk from from
the flu than they are from coven
but but there there have been some
severe reaction there are going to be
some children who react severely to
coronavirus and i'd be very curious to
know
how many of the of those kids were
overweight or obese
they're not very forthcoming with that
information but that would be that would
be an interesting thing to know
because we know that the obese are
especially susceptible to this fight the
obese especially especially susceptible
so let's shut down the parks let's shut
down the playground let's tell people
they can't go outside without a mascot
makes a lot of sense
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content